check out the new trailer for my new
movie my movie it's actually my movie
well we'll see whose movie it is when it
comes out okay check out the new trailer
for our new movie anyone but you now
better just play the trailer oh my God
enjoy hey he to the wedding of my sister
yes I am so where's your fiance wait is
this him hey I'm Ben I was for hall pass
on your break wow you are a child it's a
pretty long flight do you want anything
from the front of the boat I'm all good
on Creatine and smells like insecurity
nothing SM about me what
the that's the jerk poopy got with when
she was on a break from Jonathan I could
never be with someone like him this girl
is a
[Applause]
disastrous we been a wedding
sorry he what it going stranger what's
going on over there they dated she
crushed his heart that man does not have
a
heart no way honey look who's here who
is that my ex Jonathan my parents have
been trying to get us back together he's
like a son to us maybe we should just
tell everyone we're together what it
would solve that problem for me and you
clearly want Margaret she's seizure with
me she wants what she can't have there's
no way we can convince anyone we
actually like each other you know I
still think about that night we spent
together shut up no I'm
serious no matter how it ended it still
pretty
amazing
convincing enough let's do
it honey here he is oh no I'm with Ben
so is it like we just got together or
we' been sing around let's just be
affectionate Showtime permission to put
my left hand on your right buttock
granted not a magic
lamp hey little guy God damn it see you
tonight we have to kick it up a not nice
touch
nice oh no no it's be when are you ever
going to learn it it's
fine Titanic me are they watching are
they doing Titanic they're gone show's
over oh my
god do you have a mo or something any
but
no what
the what the one might be in
you I'm good it's probably a better way
to check than what I did it's a bad idea
right what do we miss what did we miss
it it's
fine